allez tiphaine aujourd'hui vous êtes
venus avec des livres pour rêver être
dans l'imaginaire bref des ouvrages on
va dire onirique si on cherche à moi un
peu compliqué tous parlent du bonheur et
se laisse emporter par l'imagination et
vous avez un premier livre qui nous
parle de kiki c'est ça wiki qui en
promenade je sentais que vous aviez
envie d'aller faire un tour dans la
campagne alors j'ai choisi ce livre
c'est un livre édité par les fourmis
rouges est proposée par l'illustratrice
mari me reviennent alors c'est l'idée
d'une déambulation un peu particulière
on suit julien un jeune homme rougeau
al'allure décider qui promène son chien
le mec qui qui met en fait la promenade
ne va pas se passer du tout comme prévu
puisque en fait au bout de la laisse et
bien on va découvrir que l'animal change
à chaque page il y à un aigle puis tout
d'un coup un tigre puis une chauve
souris
alors le jeune lecteur est un peu
surpris puisqu'elle se demande où est
passé kiki et puis quel animal va
apparaître et pourquoi julien ne se rend
compte de rien alors on est ici un peu
comme dans un spectacle de guignol vous
savez on a envie de prévenir le héros de
lui leur attention est ce que tu vas te
faire manger et puis ou et kiki et puis
retourne toi alors c'est à la fois très
poétique vous le voyez les illustrations
sont magnifiques un fait de collages
d'aquarelles et à la fois très amusant
alors c'est addictif je le conseille aux
enfants à partir de 2 ans et vous le
voyez c'est magnifique ça donne envie
d'aller se promener dans la nature à la
découverte pourquoi pas de d'araignée
épouvantable je ne vous raconte pas la
fin parfait kiki j'aime bien un premier
album édité par les fourmis rouges qu'on
salue tiens
grégoire vous vous le papa d'un enfant
de 4 ans bookeen un peu votre fils ou
pas on bouquine ensemble énormément et
ça pourrait tout à fait lui plaire à mes
parfums hugo tu rêves c'est le titre
c'est le premier choix de typhaine le
prochain livre est dédié aussi à tous
les enfants rêveurs ceux qui on va dire
entendre toute la journée
avais tu rêves mais et était avec nous
là qu'est ce que tu fais tu es sur ta
planète en face à va pas j'en passe et
j'en oublie un typhaine oui et celui ci
était dix départs et écrit par don par
un auteur très connu un pierre coran
alors c'est un poète c'est un auteur
jeunesse belge alors mais tu dis souvent
d'ailleurs ses poèmes à l'école et ils
adorent rêver et il aime beaucoup les
enfants rêveurs ils veulent réhabiliter
avec ce livre puisque vous savez hugo
c'est ce genre d'enfant vous l'avez dit
qu'ils ont toujours la tête dans les
nuages et pour lui et bien un lavabo
c'est plutôt une cascade et puis il
n'aime pas les gens pressés comme ça
qu'ils viennent interrompre ses rêveries
parce qu'évidemment tout le monde est
toujours très pressé et vous voyez avec
les illustrations de nathalie pauillac
et bien on découvre à la fois la réalité
est ce que voit plus beau vraiment je
vous conseille ce livre c'est
merveilleux ça fera beaucoup plaisir aux
enfants qui en ont marre qu'on les
presse toute l'année et qui ont envie de
retrouver un peu de sérénité
je vous le conseille ça marche à partir
de 4 ans les plus grands pourront le
lire eux mêmes c'est un album doux en
livrant apaisant et s'était dit et par
la maison d'édition à pas de loup je
pense que son nom tombe à point nommé
puisqu'il ne faut pas déranger et rêveur
parfait parfait le petit dernier pour la
route
un ouvrage pour les enfants à partir de
7 8 ans qui rêve où paraît-il d'une
langue universelle mais l'espoir fait
vivre
oui oui alors lothaire elsa valentin
adore inventait des langues
je vous avais déjà parlé de son livre
précédent et là cette fois le s'attaque
au mythe du petit chaperon rouge avec ce
livre chape louche car alors la magie ne
naît pas de l'histoire inquiet ultra
connus mais de la langue puisqu'elle
mêle une centaine de mots issus de
beaucoup de langues différentes ruses du
japonais
du français du wolof pour écrire et
raconter cette histoire de manière très
très poétique car je voulais juste un
petit extrait pour que vous compreniez
mieux de quoi je parle
alors par exemple on a le look y arriver
qu'il dit et lola choo les et le petit
chaperon rouge répond ikken ah ah
bonjour et toi vieux loupe les no to do
alors vous voyez cette langue roule
comme un collier de perles et c'est très
doux très poétique
on ne peut pas à la comprendre avec son
intelligence mais plutôt avec son coeur
je vous conseille vraiment ce livre
illustré par fleury sinval et publié par
siros vous trouver les mots prononcés
avec le bon accent sur le site internet
et c'est vraiment voilà un livre idéal
pour rêver de voyage de fraternité et
justement d'une langue universelle
orphée moi j'aime à retrouver cette
sélection livre évidemment sur france
point tv et sur les réseaux sociaux le
premier c'était qui clients promenade tu
très sympa hugo tu rêves
le second et le troisième chapeau rouge
cas et et cocorico parce que regarder je
sais pas si c'est un hommage aux bleus
qui vont jouer ce soir mais je vais
montrer up lama basket kit est de la
même couleur exactement la même couleur
que votre robe
ab oui mais nous sommes à l'unisson
pascal a très très bien
super maintenant aux is merci
l'acupuncteur et merci le chiropracteur
aussi de venir sur le plateau grosses
productions
non je rigole allez on va redevenir
sérieux en remerciant nos équipes qui
ont fait un boulot formidable là dessus
pour recréer cette bibliothèque
virtuelle je les salue parce que je suis
pas sûr de vous retrouver d'ici la fin
de saison on vous retrouvera en début de
rentrée un outil fans pour d'autres
aventures je suis confiant sur un hacker
bien je compte sur vous parce qu'il
viendra avec un cartable tout neuf il